here at the institute uh we're a
collaborative research institute for
theoretical computer science
uh supported in large part by the simons
foundation
and we run two programs each semester
been doing that since 2013
and each one attracting something like
60 or 70 long-term
visitors usually to berkeley and they
include a boot camp like this one and
three workshops
which also involve a lot more people so
this semester we're very happy to be
running
two programs the theoretical foundations
of computer systems
and uh satisfiability theory practice
and beyond
and together those involve around 120
long-term participants
including 13 research fellows
so welcome to the boot camp for the
theoretical foundations of computer
systems program of course
uh we're really disappointed we can't
welcome you in person to berkeley
we've got a pilot program for outdoor
in-person collaboration starting soon
as part of the semester's programs but
we can't run events like like this one
in person right now um
let me say a few words about the goals
of
these boot camps they're intended to be
a kind of social and scientific
ice breaker for the programs to get
people
talking to each other to also get them
on the same page
uh technically you know across the the
spectrum of program themes
um and i guess they they have a pretty
significant archival value as well
um a nice snapshot of the state of the
art in a field
um the the talks are all archived on our
youtube channel
and website okay let me um
introduce ashley hassan our events
coordinator ashley's
been dealing with the schedule and
logistics for the boot camp here at the
simons institute um uh she's here
somewhere on
on zoom uh so thanks to ashley for that
and you'll see her in in
gather town um uh during the week
uh also a thank you to the um organizers
of the boot camp to uh moshi vadi
to pavel chaney thomas colcombe marta
kvietkowski rujika piska
so big big thank you for putting
together a fantastic program
and a great set of speakers um
okay so um let me hand over to moshe to
say a few words about the boot camp
thank you peter so
i think you all know about the division
of
theoretical computer science into the
volume a algorithm and complexity and
volume b
more logical algorithms and
we have been putting a lot of effort to
tos tend to be more volume a volume b
is is a bit more international and
simon's design wants you to receive two
proposals one on the
theoretical foundation of computer
system and other one satisfiability and
both were
selected and but the universe seems to
be unfriendly
towards volume b and decided to throw a
monkey range there
so we have been now kind of scrambling
uh to deal with the pandemic and in
particular because volume b
is more international it it was more of
a challenge to try to figure out how do
we virtualize ourselves
because we have people here all the way
from the west coast
who are grumbling about having to get up
so early
and people on in europe who are have two
kids
puts the kids to bed and beyond europe
we just could not find
any other any other way to do that all
the other ways to do everything twice it
just
become unmanageable so we end up
converging on two
hours per day and we have what i call
seminarize all the workshops
so all the workshops are now horizontal
rather than vertical so to speak
and it's a grand experiment and we will
have to see how it works but it might be
the future of conferences
so let's all work together
i mean the organizers don't have some
magic answers we kind of rely on all of
us working collaboratively
to try to make the best of it and with
that
i'm happy to introduce our first speaker
mikolai boyancik
from warsaw who is going to give us the
boot camp on
on logic which will be complementary to
the
in particular uh nikolai lecture and on
the cufferman lectures are going to be
quite complementary
really kind of two pieces of lego
fitting together
so i encourage you to the minimum to try
to attend both
because i think you'll see the same
elephant from two different perspectives
nikolai thank you mosha
uh since i have small kids i i get to
know a lot about legos and i'm afraid
that i hope that they will not be like
cheap legos which don't really fit
together
together so thanks a lot for this
introduction i'm i'm rather stressed to
open
what mostly called the future of
conferences
and my stress is also increased by my
rather presumptuous title which is a
logic
and so logic is of course a huge field
and
i i'm not competent to speak about it
well moshe probably would be
a in full generality so i will give a
very biased talk and now we're all
familiar with biased communication
so uh there will be something that i
will should i say but i will not say at
all and there will be some things that i
will say twice
and so that's going to be my bias and
the bias is uh
is towards automata which is a the
central topic of ernest's talk tomorrow
now since uh since these slides are
available uh online with with the
with sound well a super set of these
slides and
i think the value of this particular
meeting is that you can interrupt me all
the time
so i think it's not important if i reach
the end of my slides
as long as if at any moment you want to
say something you want to criticize
something you want to say that you think
about it differently
please go ahead and do so it's it's it's
this is what i mean
it's supposed to be interactive okay uh
so don't worry if we don't go
reach the and end of the slides
so i'll begin uh by saying what i will
not talk about
so as i say it would be rather
presumptuous for me to say that i'm
talking about logic in general so logic
is huge
and uh i will be mainly uh talking about
kkk are my slides visible not yet
oh okay that was a big uh no we need a
who is the host of the meeting actually
maybe i think i didn't press a button
okay okay they're visible now yes
yeah uh so uh it's
it's not going to be in general about
logic in computer science
but uh it will revolve around uh first
order logic
and uh its variance and uh well you know
which formulas are true in which mode so
i'll try to give you
uh a brief overview of some
mainly very old results
about how can you have algorithms that
that check properties of formulas
and uh my bias will be about algorithms
which which uh this use automata
okay and uh so there's lots of aspects
of logic that i will not talk about so
maybe if
i guess i mean i guess if you're in the
us then probably
logic means boolean formulas under
satisfiability and
and i guess if you're in the sat program
that's also an indication that you might
think about this i will not talk about
that
it's a huge topic not not discussed
i will not talk about other aspects of
logic such as i don't know
intuitionistic logic which due to its
connection with lambda calculus is also
an important topic in in
in theoretical computer science uh this
is something that i will not talk about
i will not talk about proof assistance
again a big topic now and and
this is also logic uh i i just list a
number of things that came to my head
uh uh associate free associations with
the word logic which i'm not going to
talk about
i'm not going to talk about proof theory
and i'm not going to talk about say
temporal logic something that will
probably play a role in in horna's
tutorial tomorrow okay what i will talk
about
is uh well
this problem which is the satisfiability
a problem
of deciding if a formula phi is true in
some model
typically is going to be a formula of
say first order logic or some variance
and then the question is going to be
what to do about the fact that this is
an undecidable problem
and in my talk it's going to be what to
do about this fact in a way that
involves the word automaton
another problem that i will also discuss
is the model checking problem
so deciding if a formula where we have
the model we have the formula
and we want to know the formula is true
and then this model checking problem can
be discussed from
several different perspectives i think
that mostly would call them a data
complexity a
query complexity and combined complexity
uh
which would be one variant is that we
fix uh
the the model and then we uh the formula
is is the input
and then you have the other combinations
okay
so my my talk will be uh structured
around these three
three problems and i will begin uh with
this one which i think is maybe the most
classical problem like a hundred years
old
in logic so which is we think some
important structures that we care about
i don't know the real numbers for
example with
the field operations and we want to know
which
formulas are true there and then
i will also discuss the satisfiability
problem with as i say an emphasis on on
automata methods
and uh finally i will uh discuss
the the the model checking problem where
we fix that formula
and then the structure is given on input
so typically it's going to be
a a finite structure that i will care
about
okay so uh let me
just i want to say that there are slides
for each of these parts and they're
more in in-depth but here i just want to
go go over well
some subset of these these results so
let's begin
with the problem where we have
fix a structure and then we want to
we're given an input a formula first
order logic
and we want to know if it's true and
the an algorithm so just in case you
don't remember first order logic
is is the logic where it's it's not
propositional logic
it's where you get to you have a
structure which has elements and you get
to quantify over them
and the structure has extra well
structure relations
and you get to write about that in your
formula so here's a formula which tells
you i guess that the relation the binary
relation r
is a function okay uh
so the problem that i will discuss in
this first part
is uh you have a structure m
and you want to know when is it let's
just say decidable
and if decidable then what is the
computational complexity
of the problem we are given uh on input
a formula well a sentence a formula
without any free variables and want to
know if it's true in our structure
so let me begin from the low side so
well maybe the simplest possible
structure you can imagine there's just
two elements
and it has only one relation which is
equality well actually
i will always assume that equality is
for free uh
there are one this is not a a an obvious
assumption but this is one i will make
and uh so i could just say there's no
relations but i feel uncomfortable
uh not indicating a list of relations so
i just write equality
and then for even
already for this simplest structure the
the problem of giving a formula whether
or not it's true there is p space
complete and it's easy to
uh encode quantified boolean formulas
where
uh one is uh true and zero is false or
actually the opposite way because you
you have
with equality only you don't know which
one is true or which ones
the very very left of the of the slide
is chopped when i look at it
is that true for every uh other people
it's true for me yes okay if there is a
way you can
it's like one character is missing if
you can shift it right a little bit
yeah okay then i have to exit full
screen uh
okay now now we see the whole thing
before that we saw earth
earth other logic well that way you
could i could
claim a new logic yes
is it is it now is the logic it returns
to its classical form
yes yes uh well that's the only thing we
needed one more logic
yes okay
so if you fix a structure which is
finite
uh such as the simplest possible
structure is going to be p space
hard and it's also going to be p space
because the naive algorithm
where you just uh every quantifier you
replace it by a for loop it is going to
run in polynomial
polynomial space and because every
element can be represented in in
logarithmic space
so there's not much interesting to say
about
the decidability or complexity about
the model checking problem if we fix a
finite structure and and you we vary the
formula
so the interesting cases are when we
have an infinite structure
and then it's not clear if it should be
decidable and actually this is going to
be maybe the focus of
of of of this part of the top so
decidable or not
so i guess a a super classical one would
be something a structure that's called i
think arithmetic without any adjectives
and uh here we have to that they say the
natural numbers or the integers it
doesn't matter
with the the field operations and uh
if you are given a a formula of first
order logic and you want to
know if it's true in in this particular
structure this is an undecidable
problem and this is well it's roughly a
gathers proof
because you can encode a list of numbers
using a single number
and using a list of numbers you can
encode the computation of a turing
machine
so once you are comfortable with these
types of encodings then you can just
write in
in a formula which says that
this uh such and such turing machine
holds so it's an undecidable problem
and uh this motivates the search for you
know you know
for which structures can you make it
decidable and a famous result
uh which is uh due to tarsky and i think
it was proved uh well
he he proved it before the war but the
published results are in berkeley
were published when he came to berkeley
after the war
uh it says that if you uh
consider the field of real numbers then
the problem given a sentence whether or
not it's true
it is it is a decidable problem
and this already is connected with a
method
which is the quantifier elimination
method so what pranatarsky showed
is that the this theory is decidable
because it has quantifier elimination in
the following sense
so for every formula which may have
three variables
uh it is actually equivalent to a finite
boolean combination of polynomial
inequalities
so here a polynomial it has integer
coefficients and it uses the
the variables from the formula uh
so for example consider a formula which
has
three variables a b c which are free
and it says that the quadratic
polynomial
uh a x squared plus b
x squared plus c has well a yeah the
quadratic polynomial of coefficients abc
has at least one root so according to
carski's result this is described by a
quantifier free formula
polynomial a combination of polynomial
inequalities in in the free variables
and actually if you figure it out it's
it's it's something that i guess kids
learn in school which
says that in poland this is called the
delta so we we say that uh
b squared minus four ac is is is is
greater or equal to zero so tarsky's
theorem is aware of this result and
and other results i think it's a funny
story because uh
uh if you look at atarski's original
proof it is well
if you like look at the heart of it
it's just uh taking a school algorithm
for describing uh
the shape of a polynomial with one
variable
and uh tarsky uh before the uh
when he was in poland he was teaching
high school mathematics
in a girl high school so a story that i
made up
is that when he was teaching this high
school mathematics he got
bored because he just keep on proving
you know
analyzing the shape of this polynomial
with one free variable always using the
same tools and so
like a lesser person such as myself
would go oh i'm such a great scientist
why do i have to teach about polynomials
i should be doing more important things
and leotarsky was not such a person
so he decided oh okay i'm teaching this
stuff which i find boring but
why is it boring and in what way is it
boring and
and then he formalized that it is boring
in the sense that there is a decision
procedure which does this
uh i i i talked to some historians
of of of mathematical teaching and i
think there's evidence that my story
doesn't add up but uh
uh it's a it's a story okay sino
averro uh so another example of a
a story well there's no story here uh is
press bulgar arithmetic
uh well so it
pasca arithmetic is kind of strange
because you think that there's more real
numbers than natural numbers so
they should be harder but they're easier
so somehow it's hard if you're dealing
with natural numbers as opposed
to to to real numbers
and press burger consider the case okay
we use the hard natural numbers but we
don't have multiplication have addition
only
and then he proved that this theory is
decidable so if you're given a first
order formula
uh when you can't say much you can say
maybe something like there's infinitely
many even numbers because you can say
there's uh
for every y x there exists a bigger y
such that y
is equal to z plus z for some set that's
a
thing you can say in principle get
arithmetic maybe not super exciting as a
mathematical theorem
and then press bulgar well it's this is
modern terminology
he showed that every such formula has a
normal form which is well
now it's called semi-linear sets and and
you can effectively transform
every formula into a semi-linear set and
and work with these in a computable way
and actually press burger arithmetic i
mean i'm sure some many of you know this
it's a fundamental logic and
verification because you can
many things are decidable because you
can express
well at least a simple argument for
decidability that you can express them
uh just using this logic there's also an
analog and a similar thing to presburger
arithmetic which is called scaling
arithmetic where you get to
multiply but you don't get to add and it
is also
decidable okay so that
those are some of my examples of
structures which have a decidable first
order theory
uh then you can go to higher logic
so one logic and this is actually the
direction that i'm interested in
in this talk mainly uh so you could say
well
why not just why do i quantify just over
elements why not quantify over sets or
maybe
over uh say
relations so relations of variety two
are set is absolution variety one and so
on
and this one is also kind of trivial
from this perspective
because if you take any finite structure
then a second order logic is going to be
p space complete for it
uh so the well the lower bound is
inherited from first order logic
uh now here you don't even need to
assume that there's a two elements
and the upper bound is just again the
the the the
uh the the trivial algorithm
uh and it is undecidable for every
infinite structure because if you get an
infrastructure and
then you can uh guess addition and
multiplication using second-order logic
and
and be done with it so there's not much
to say for second-order logic
but this leads me to the logic which is
the one that i care about
most of all in my talk which is uh well
if you haven't seen it
i i cannot imagine that somebody has not
seen it but
if if you are such a person then it
might be surprising but it turns out to
be extremely
important in this field which is monadic
second order
so this is like second order logic but
it is restricted so
when you uh you get to quantify over
elements uh but you
uh only get to when you want to talk
about
objects of a higher order such as binary
relations and so on
you only get to do unary relations miku
like quick interrupt
no i said no interruptions no you
invited interruption
go ahead fix structure here right
yes um did i make a mistake somewhere
why is it p space
well you can uh did i make a mistake
here so you
you in the upper bound yeah yeah i mean
because now to represent a relation
it's of exponential size right
yeah yeah correct that's it no but it's
a fixed finite structure
so it's constant size i know it
constants that but the relations are
fixed the clarity of the relation is
part of the input then in fact moshe is
right i i
made a mistake relations of exponential
size here
so this is some kind of the this is some
weird really complex class in the
in the yeah yeah i'm sorry yes so it's a
it's between exponential and then p
space yeah that's so it's it's it's it's
you're right
it there is a a i guess a class for that
yes
so thanks
in my hurry to disregard second order
logic i i i
i run over a pedestrian i i
i i apologize anyway what i want to talk
about
is this mso okay uh
so it turns out that this logic uh
it can be quite well understood and this
will be the main theme of my
my talk here so let's begin with uh so
this is uh
i think it's a question that uh as far
as i know comes uh
it goes back to tarsky it's it's i think
there's a from his lectures
uh in the 50s in berkeley which is uh
what if i take the
ordered natural numbers and then
i just i ask which monadic second order
logic formulas are true there
so i fix this structure of the order
natural numbers and
i'm given an input a a formula an mso
formula and i want to know if it's true
so for example if you don't have the
order then it's kind of easy to see that
the problem is decidable
because roughly speaking you can uh
first mso doesn't contribute anything
you can
eliminate set quantifiers the only thing
you can say is that this set has
at least 10 elements and this element
belongs to that set so this is a it's
i think a rather easy argument but if
you have order then the
things become quite interesting and uh
by surveying like the first result which
was uh approved on this topic which is
that a variant of this problem
is indeed decidable the problem itself
is also decidable that would be later
but the variant will be somehow most
connected to what i will talk about
later in my talk uh so uh
weak mso it's it's it the syntax is the
same as
mso so you have quantifiers which say
for every element
x or existing element x and you have
quantifiers which says
exists a set x and for every set x
however well it's a different text a
capital x because it's a set
however the semantics are different so
when you quantify over a set it's meant
to be a finite set
so for example if you write the formula
on the left
well it's the same formula but you
understand it in two different ways if
it says
there is a set which contains all
elements then this is true if you allow
infinite set but it's false if you
only allow finite sets so in principle
these logics are different
so they're incomparable somehow
but for the natural numbers we've
ordered they're comparable because you
can express
in the full mso non-weak logic data
satisfy night by saying
there is a finite upper bound on its
elements
and therefore uh every formula of weak
mso
can be converted into an equivalent
formula of non-weak mso
but as it so happens the conversion is
also true but that's a non-trivial
result
okay so
this is a theorem and you will find a
maybe slightly unusual list of authors
here
of of length five
[Music]
and i'll explain this unusuality in a
moment
which is that this is the late 1950s
which says that the week
this this week theory so the question of
given a
formula of weakness or whether or not
it's through the national numbers this
is a decidable problem
so uh why is that well the idea is a
as a frequent idea if you want to prove
a theorem about
a logic which has quantifiers you
typically want to prove something about
sub formulas and
and and therefore if you want to have do
an induction over formula size for
example
and therefore you need to treat formulas
which have some free variables so
consider a formula which has three
variables in this case
three so it has a first order variable x
which is meant to refer to an element
a natural number and two uh second order
variables y and z which are meant to
refer to as
finite sets of natural numbers now this
formula has a semantics so describe
it describes us a set of triples of of
the form
a value for x a value for y a value for
z
x is going to be a number y and z are
going to be finite sets of numbers
and uh you might want to wonder how you
can represent this in a finite way
so for example in tarsky arithmetic we
would say you can represent this using a
boolean combination of polynomial
inequalities in presburger's theorem we
would say you can represent this using a
semi-linear set whatever that means and
uh
that's not going to work here and what
is going to work and this is an
incredibly influential idea is that
we're going to use an automaton
to represent this set so how do you do
it well
imagine that you have uh say the a
possible
values of the variables so you have a
number x
and two sets y and z and both since the
sets are finite
you can just write them as a word
where the i flatter tells you
about with the number i which sets it
does it belong
to so you write well uh since y and z
are set you can get
plus or minus in some configuration of
pluses and minuses
and since uh lowercase x is just a
number you get exactly one plus
because there's exactly one number which
is equal to it and since these sets
are meant to be finite because we're
talking about weak mso
then at some point it's just minuses
everywhere so you can cut off the word
and you can
this way you can represent your variable
evaluation
as a finite word over an eight letter
alphabet in this case
uh which tells you yeah
the columns of the picture so this way
you can represent
uh the the values of the variables as a
finite word
and you can use automata so the lemma
that you prove
is that for every formula it some of the
three variables are
elements some of them are sets and then
you say that there is and actually in
fact can be computed
a finite automaton that tells you if if
a representation of the variables
is correct or not so how do you do this
and it's a it's a very simple idea
so you just do a an induction on formula
size
and if you think about the the atomic
formulas which says
this variable belongs to that set that's
something you can say in qmso or this
variable is smaller than that one
the corresponding languages are easily
seen to be a
done by finite automata which i think
have two or three states in each case
okay and then uh if you uh
how else can you construct formulas you
can take boolean combinations
and everybody knows that languages
recognized by
a finite automata are closed under
boolean combinations
so that's going to work out
and then you have to treat a quantifier
and this
is an idea which maybe if you haven't
seen it it's it's it's worth to uh
explain in with a picture which is that
quantifiers of logic correspond to
projection
so what does that mean so imagine i have
a formula with
some here okay here some three variables
maybe all of them are elements it
doesn't matter
they could be sets so it it it there's a
corresponding
language and a word okay they should
have been sets because there's lots of
pluses
a word which describes them looks like
looks like this so
now if you uh create a quantifier
then the words which satisfy the
quantified formula
are obtained by the words by taking a
word which satisfies the unquantified
formula i'm just removing one row
the last row in this case the one that
corresponds to the quantified variable
and so that means that uh the the
corresponding logical operation is just
a projection it means it's an operation
which takes words and
for each letter removes some information
in case the in this case the last last
bit
and if you think now about regular
languages they're easily seen to be
closed under projection
because one way to see it for example is
if you take a regular expression
and then you just for each for the
language before quantification and then
for each letter you just write the
corresponding letter with the last bit
remove them and you get a regular
expression for the protector
okay uh so that shows that automata have
all of the
properties which you would require of
logic and therefore
they can be used as a normal form for
logic and
if you care about complexity then it's
not going to be so good
because for if you want to do a
boolean operations especially
complementation you would
typically be interested in having a
deterministic automaton because
complementation doesn't work well with
non-deterministic automata
and if you're going to be dealing with
projection the opposite is true you are
going to
typically interested in
non-deterministic automata and
and if your formula switches between a
quantification
and existential quantification and
complementation
end times and you're going to be you're
going to find yourself determinizing an
automaton
end times and then doing making not just
deterministic and so you will have n
times you will have an exponential
and this is actually optimal so so it's
it is of non-elementary complexity
this translation so it's it's it's more
and for the
exponential in the sense of
computational complexity where
n is the number of alternations so it's
not so good in terms of complexity
but it's it's a decidable problem okay
uh so this is uh this is the
automata method and it turns out to be
incredibly
flexible and i will give you some very
important generalizations of it later on
but i would not discuss them in detail
in this particular talk so maybe you
might want to ask
what is my letters uh
so uh one of them is t for trachtenbroe
so drachtenbrot wrote the paper in
1957 were submitted in 1957
about uh i guess and i'm not sure how
my pronunciation is good about the
synthesis of logical nets
which are described by a a one-place
predicate so by
monadic secondary logic and he proved
the the theorem there
so this is a paper was published in in
in the quad
in the proceedings of the soviet academy
of sciences in 1958.
that is a one source it's it's three
pages
long or four pages long and to be honest
i'm not sure if the proof checks out but
uh but you know i'm not a fluent russian
speaker so there there could be
and and it's nice because one of the
technical definitions is a sputnik
so this is a clearly sign of the times
so
every formula has its sputnik
that's one source and the the other
famous source is is is
is a paper well this is a conference
version of bihi and elgat and then their
journal papers are separated in
in the same year and uh so the
conference version is short enough that
i can put it here in full
so here it is and that's the entire
conference paper
uh and um i think you've got to infer
some of the information from the kinds
of capital or lowercase letters that
they use
but that's a it's an abstract and the
theorem says here and you can see that
the main theorem is not the decidability
of the logic
uh but it is the automata method that is
highlighted
as the main result of of of the paper
however uh if you open this you see at
the next line
it's kind of funny because whenever you
open an old paper you find something
strange uh uh in it which says that
actually the
the theorem about logic itself was known
before
uh and this is a eren feud and vote and
this is the e and v
in in in my list of authors and uh
there's a very nice paper by wolfgang
thomas you can which appeared in the
zyglock
newsletter i think two years ago which
explains the story behind that
uh so the original proof actually of
these results was was was aaron
vote and uh and the idea there is to
encode finite words using ordinals
and so uh like uh omega square and omega
to the third and so on
and uh and then there is a result that
the ordinal arithmetic is is decidable
and you can reduce it to that
so this is our uh story maybe
one more thing that's nice in this
abstract is uh
is that a corollary er er
of uh of that already pointed out by
duhinel god
a corollary is that presburger
arithmetic is decidable
and it may be a a nice to to explain how
because it's a it's very simple and
yet yet also i think quite an important
idea
so what is that so what i want to show
is using
this weak mso theory i want to conclude
that presburger arithmetic so the
natural numbers of addition but not with
multiplication
is a decidable theory so you can
represent that and how is that done
well the idea is the obvious one uh you
uh take a natural number and you
represent it using a set which
a finite set which describes the binary
expansion so you just do the binary
expansion and the
digits in that binary expansion is your
finite set it's just clear
okay and now well you have to say that
addition can be defined
so uh what you show but this is a
school stuff is that you can write an
msl formula for x plus y equals z
because you just have to say how you do
addition you know
three numbers there's like a bit for
carry or something and you can all
formalize this
by using set quantification and uh
thanks to that
we know that if i take any formula of
pris bulgaria arithmetic which has
some three variables each one
representing a number then the
corresponding nre relation on
binary expansions it can be is definable
in a weak mso and therefore also by
by an automaton and can be
which can be computed effectively uh
so uh but actually this method allows
you to decide more than press book
arithmetic you can add some other stuff
that you could do with an automaton but
you cannot do with press burger
automaton such as saying that a number
is a power of two
because if you have a binary expansion
then it's easy to see if it's a power of
two it's just
you know well it just has one digit one
one non-zero digit
and then you can actually find out some
kind of rather artificial
i would say a predicate which you can
also do and then once you have that
actually then
it starts to become equivalent to
automata so if you extend press burger
arithmetic with
with these things then you get exactly
the same thing as as
as automata and uh well
uh this uh this result if i say well i
said press bulgaria arithmetic
is is natural numbers but if it's
integers nothing changes
and uh this is an example of uh
this this phenomenon here is something
that's called an automaton group
so unfortunately the word automaton
group can be understood in three
different
ways which is a little bit confusing so
one of them the one that i'm using here
is actually the one that is never used
which is that you can represent the
elements of the group by words
and the well the three places the group
operation is and now there's an
automaton for that
that is not a way that anybody uses it
but there there are two other
understandings uh one of them is that
an automaton group and this is the this
is the the main one
you can represent
the the elements by words
and then it's supposed to be finitely
generated and for every genera
generator the operation of multiplying
by that generator
is implementable by an automaton and
that is something that is popular in
in in group theory i think that this was
originally proposed by by the famous
geometer uh william thurston and then
there's there's that there's
it it's it's it's a thing uh
uh and then you can generalize this
notion to well
structures which are representable by
automating not necessarily
uh that are not necessarily groups uh
which was done by nerodian husseinoff
and then just to complete the confusion
there is a third understanding of
automaton groups
which i think automat and i think these
are not automatic
groups but they are automaton groups and
this is a completely different notion
again popular in group theory
well some kind of popularity where an
automaton group is as follows obtained
as follows
you take a word towards transformation
which is uh definable by an automaton a
transducer
and then if your transducer happens to
be reversible then there's a natural
group structure to it or you can invert
it
so you take several such transducers and
then the group
of string to string transformations
generated by them and the
groups of this shape are called
automaton groups i believe
and then they are they can be they're i
think they're the
world leading the counter examples to
some group theoretic
conjectures such as
the burnside question so that's
but that's just a little digression
about uh groups
so let's continue uh with our main theme
so uh uh these people where b here got
them tracked and brought
they proved that logic is equivalent
automatic
in this case logic being weaker missile
and then
this was uh continued and uh by two
by b he himself uh to prove the original
problem decidable
and uh then it was also continued
famously by by
rabin to uh for a generalization where
you have instead of the natural numbers
which is a linear order
you have all strings ordered by prefix
relation which is like a branching order
a tree order
and both of these theories are decidable
and in both cases it is because
of automata now in my in my extended
slides i
i discussed just a little bit about what
these automata are about but not so much
but the general idea of the proof is the
same you define a notion of automaton
which is expressive enough
uh to uh but it has to work over
infinite objects now
to be uh closed under boolean
combinations and projection
and then the difficulty is in both cases
the main difficulty is showing that
non-deterministic automata are closed
under
uh complementation and you can do it
without uh
going through deterministic automata and
then it's different well there's stuff
to say about that but i think orna will
mention at least some things about that
and then maybe just to mention one uh
like end of the line result there's a
if you take the real numbers with order
uh then in fact the mso theory is
undecidable so this is uh
this is an ordered structure uh but the
automata don't seem to work there
and i think i have nothing to say in
like one line about this result except
that it's
approved using you have to be crazy to
prove it if you look at it
he manages to encode in the end
arithmetic like natural numbers and
addition
uh but it is uh well it's just crazy i
mean um
the way you represent a natural number
as a set of real numbers
is is is just but it's it's it's it's
it's a yeah it's a it's it's
an interesting story but maybe for
another time
okay so that's a brief overview of a
fear of
structures which have a decidable mso
theory
uh and that concludes my part where i
fix the structure and then i
i i ask about the formula and then
the examples that i cared about mainly
were where the structure is infinite so
it's not obvious if the problem is going
to be decidable
and then the answer was well by finding
suitable
kinds of ultimate so let me go now to
the second part
which is uh where i am just given the
formula
and i want to know if it's true in way
okay
and then this is this will be studied in
several different variants
uh well there will be which logic do i
care about
and which what do i mean by model so if
you take the
the the most natural formulation where
the logic is first order logic and then
uh the class of models is say all models
uh then this is just hilbert's and
sightings problem
this is a well i think gilbert stated it
as
is not satisfiability but validity so is
it true in all models but uh well and
then
in hilbert's case it was i guess more
proof theoretically stated but it's uh
it's uh but this is a
equivalent uh and uh uh that was the the
the original gangster of of
of decidability problems and uh
famously it was shown undecidable by
church and touring i mean they have this
to
define what it means to be decidable in
order to
to prove that it's undecidable but they
did that and then they showed that it is
indeed
not decidable so it's a foundational the
original undecidable problem
uh okay so if you want to avoid this
undecidability
uh then there are two ways to go one is
to restrict the models and one is to
restrict the logic
now i will not say anything about
restricting the logic in my talk
i'll just mention some examples are like
one
example is that if you only allow two
variables in your formulas
well at first it seems that you can't do
anything
but in fact you can do some things and
this has been quite a
quite an intense civilly studied field
in the last few decades and there's
techniques
to solve that which unfortunately do not
involve automata
but they involve say linear
but integral linear inequalities
frequently as a tool
and then there's a there's a there's
lots of other fragments that people have
introduced
uh but i this is something i don't want
to talk about what i do want to talk
about is restricting the models so
in the original problem you care about
any model
if you say just for finite models it is
also undecidable so that doesn't help
you
uh but as we will see in the in the
following a few slides
uh if you just care about models which
uh
which are like words or trees then you
you can get something from automata
nikolai we don't see the bottom of the
slide now axis 2 at the bottom we don't
quite see do you
want us to see how much do you want us
to see
how much do you see on your screen uh
well
there's an arrow which points downward
uh is it better now
um okay now we see the whole
axis 2 but just the text is there some
there's something smaller that i cannot
read at the very bottom
am i supposed to read it do you see
a downward pointing arrow with its arrow
head no
no
okay that's uh like what can i do
is it better now uh no now it chops
okay make it smaller let me see you know
what i'll try something else
i'll i'll try to do a a an entire screen
okay uh
that will help somebody said you should
try to do alt
f5 now that's that's
uh is it do you see now um
okay at the bottom there is some color
am i supposed to see i see
okay it's good the color is a progress
bar is that do you see a process
yeah yeah now i see the progress oh yeah
okay good
and uh is there a
okay
now i see the progress bar okay but do
you see something
except for the progress bar like the
slides for example yeah yes i see the
slide now
now this is okay yeah i think we're
better now thank you moshe i appreciate
that because otherwise there will be
nobody who'll be telling me that you
can't see my slides and that would be
like uh
this reminds me of a prank that some
colleagues did of mine did
so so they they were cleaning toilets as
a summer job and
uh one of them like to tell a lot of
stories
uh so he went into the toilet where to
use it actually and then
he started telling a story and they
encouraged him to tell his longest
possible story and then they left
the toilet so he was there telling this
story alone and then people would be
coming into the toilet and they would
find this guy
speaking from a toilet and i was afraid
that i would be like that person
so thanks for for stopping me
where was i um restrict a lot
more yes restricted models yes
uh so uh
one axis is going to be words and truth
uh and then from that i will say that
you can push this further and
if you i'd like to mention tree with
which is an
important option and uh that's going and
as it will turn out this is
a at least if your logic is mso this is
not only something you can do but it is
the only thing that you can do which is
nice because then you can understand
exactly for which models
the problem is deciding so this gives
you a clean
theory so let me begin with words and
trees
so this automata method that i mentioned
with bikiel got on track and brought
whether the the theorem can be stated i
stated it in terms of natural numbers
but you can state it as follows this is
the way it's more usually stated is that
if you have a finite word over some
alphabet
then you can view it as a logical
structure where the underlying set is
the positions in the word and then you
have one binary relation for order
and you have one unary relation for
every letter of the alphabet which is
true
in positions with that label and then if
you have a formula of mso
which uses these predicates then it's
true in some words and it's not true in
other words and therefore you can think
of it as
defining a property of words as long as
you just
evaluate evaluated on structures which
come from words so for example if you
take the formula which says
for every x there exists a y which is
bigger and has label a
as long as you're talking about finite
words this formula describes
and your alphabet is a b you're
describing the regular language of words
which end with a
so this is a regular language and it's
no coincidence
because these are the same things so
regular languages are exactly the same
thing
as a finite automata and
well if you want to go from mso to
regular languages you observe
well this we already did this proof in
fact that
the finite automata they have the all of
the closure properties
necessary to to deal with formulas and
if you want to go in the other way
it's it's very simple uh you just
formalize and logic
the fact that an automaton accepts a
word and it's it's it's not so hard to
do so these are equivalent formalism and
this is i think that the
the how people view their behalf
theorem nowadays i'd like to uh uh so
uh so this is how you can view it that
uh
uh you can frame it in terms of
satisfiability
that given an mso sentence you can
decide if it's true in at least one word
and the reason why that's true is that
you can compile the formula into an
automaton and check if that automation
is is is not non-empty i'm sorry to
interrupt you again so now we have
chopping on left and right and the
bottom as well
that's very bizarre people well thanks
for for telling this but it's uh
there's no nothing happening on my side
and yet it's it's
okay i'll do something uh maybe i'll uh
do a different thing then michelle are
you sharing your whole application or
just
or the desktop i'm just sharing the
desktop
uh let me maybe i'll
do something i'll i'll not use my extra
screen
uh and uh i'll i'll do this
something like
um can you see my slides again
yes now it looks perfect now
okay for a moment but then i will be
glancing sideways at you
so
okay well too bad uh
and one thing that i want to mention uh
here
which is expanded a little bit in my
slides is that there's a third approach
popular especially in
in baguette eating countries which is uh
to use ammonoids
instead of automata and this is a
i'll try to agree argue in my slides
it's it's a
it's it's quite a powerful approach and
for example because monoids they have a
better structural and mathematical
theory than automata so for an automaton
i mean what kind of decomposition
results you have in automata what can
you do in automaton i don't know
strongly connected components uh number
of transitions that's basically
what you can do with an automaton so
it's not very you know uh
very uh exciting uh but monoids they
have a very nice theory where you can
use the word group
and uh and and other things and then
this is a
quite a useful theory so just want to
encourage you to find out about monoids
if you
uh yeah i just wanted you to encourage
to find out about mines
anyway uh the theorem about
regular languages equal to mso
it is a it is it is true for many other
things
so for example for
infinite words because there are
automata for infinite words it is true
for finite trees and also infinite trees
and because there are automata for all
of these objects and the automata are
designed in such a way that they have
the mso closure properties
now uh i like to from all of these
things i'd like to mention
well the one which is technically
simplest which is finite trees
because this will appear later on so
what is an automaton for a finite tree
so here's a picture
so you have a finite tree uh
where you have nodes which are labeled
by the alphabet
and uh uh and say it's it's finitely
branching
and well it's a finite tree so it's
finally branching in particular
and the way you run an automaton for it
on it is that well in a word you put
states between letters
so you do the same thing for a tree you
put states between letters but now
that it's branching so so there's
there's states like that and then so
your transitions just tell you
uh uh as usual in automation what is
locally permissible so when
can so is when our state's consistent in
the
uh environment of a single tree node so
that's your notion of transitions
and this was worked out by hatteran
right in 1968
and they turned out to be clo didn't
determinize and be closed under uh
complement boolean boolean opera
operations
because of determinization and uh
because of non-determinism they're also
closed under projections so
they're equivalent to mso this is
technically uh rather simple
when you go to infinite trees as in
raven's theorem it becomes
enormously more complicated but i don't
want to talk about raven's theorem
but already the finite tree automata
turned out to be a very interesting
departure point as i will explain in a
moment
so that's word and trees but it does
sound a little bit ad hoc okay so we
have some method which allows us to
treat some very special cases of models
so models which
describe words and trees and
some kind of way that's in it
constructed to uh to
to be a compatible with automata but as
i will try to explain to you in a moment
it turns out that it is not so ad-hoc at
all
so this is connected to treatment
so let's say that i move beyond the
words and i go to graphs and graphs
can actually be thought of as
representing arbitrary structures and
this is provably so in this in this
context so let's think about
say undirected and finite graphs and
then again you can model a graph
as as a logical structure there are
several ways to do it the one that i
will use here
is that the underlying set is the
vertices and the edges
and you have one binary relation which
tells you this vertex is a
incident or adjacent to that edge
there's other ways to do it
so for example you could say that the
underlying set is vertices only and
there's a binary relation for edges
if your logic is first order logic it
doesn't matter if your logic is mso
there's a difference uh
but i i will focus on the incident model
and i'll explain the the the the red
thing later on
okay and this way you can express
properties of graphs
so what can you say you can say for
example that the graph is connected in
msl because when is a graph disconnected
a graph is disconnected you can find two
disjoint sets of vertices which are
closed undertaking edges
so you can express being disconnected
which you could not do in first order
logic
okay and uh
if you consider graphs you can study the
satisfiability problem
both for mso and first order logic but
in both cases it is undecidable
and it is well roughly for the same
reasons as the as in sightings problem
because you can encode arbitrary
uh structures inside graphs uh so this
is a this is an undecidable problem
and but there's a reason for it so if
you look at the reason why
first order logic is undecidable uh on
graphs or mso is on the sideboard graphs
the reason is that you can have graphs
which look like this
so if you have a graph that looks like
this and say you have
a mso quantification
then you can color it with with the
computation of a turing machine the rows
are the configurations
and then you you you can encode the
halting problem
and if it's first order logic then okay
maybe you need to have some
colors somehow in your graph but the but
the
the the the graphs that are important
are grid like
okay but what about graphs that are not
grid like
so here's a picture of a graph that
doesn't look like a grid and it's
supposed to look a little bit like a
tree
if if your eyesight is not good okay
and it turns out that graphs which are
similar to trees well
they're similar to trees so things are
good so let me
quantify this similarity and this is an
ocean which is called tree with
and i will describe it using uh a again
a french way
uh inspired by by by corsair's
terminology
uh which is so using something as an
algebraic structure
we're using something called the graphs
with ports i think crusader would call
it graphs with sources
so the idea is this you're dealing with
objects which it's a graph
and there's some distinguished vertices
which are colored here in red and i call
them parts
okay and then we can put them together
in
several ways
that i will describe in a moment and
then i will say that a graph
is similar to a tree if it can be
obtained from graphs with a small number
of ports
using these operations so the definition
is that the graph has a tree with
a k it's a number if it can be
constructed using
graphs with ports that have at most k
plus one parts
and using the following operations so
the first operation is a constant
so you can start with any graph with
ports as long as all of your vertices
are ports
so if k plus one is your upper bound on
the number of parts then you can create
a graph that most uh
k plus one vertices because they are
have to be read
the second operation is you input a
graph and you indicate one of the ports
and it stops being a port
because well you know you want to
allocate a new port that's the general
idea okay and then the output is
is the graph with that port no longer
being a port and then the last operation
is a fuse operation
where you have two graphs with ports and
you have a bijection between some of the
ports
and then you just join them along that
by text
so there's well it's a bit
underspecified here
so uh uh well but these are details i
don't want to
so that's that's the operations you have
and if you manage to create a graph
using these operations and keeping a
small number of parts
then that means you have a small tree
width so let's see an example
so let me generate a cycle an eighth len
a cycle of length eight
using uh at most three parts and
therefore it has three to two
this k plus one is just it's a nuisance
it's defined uh
so that the trees have treated one uh so
how do you create a cycle let's begin
with this little piece of a cycle
everything is a port so we're allowed to
do that because there's three ports
uh then we forget one of them then on
the side we could generate a new piece
of a cycle and then we merge them
together using this fuse operation
and so we have a bit of a longer cycle
now and then
we forget so the the important part of
the cycle is the end points
and then on the side we like attach to
it another piece of a cycle
and then we prolonged it we forget again
so we managed to create a longer path
and in fact we could go on so forever
but i want to accelerate a little bit so
i do a symmetric film from the bottom
and then i fuse them and i get my eight
cycle and then i forget all of my
vertices
so you can see now why it's called tree
width because uh
the reason why something can be
generated is a tree
it's a tree of operations because it's
an algebra so it's a
so that's the tree okay
and in fact this works for it doesn't
matter what's the length of the cycle
okay so that's through it and then it
turns out that uh
tree width is exactly what you can do if
you want mso to be decidable
so let me state this so uh this is a
something that was well this study of of
mso on graphs was initiated by cursel
and he showed well that the foreign
problem is decidable you are given an
mso sentence and a bound on the truth
and you want to know
if the sentence is true in some finite
graph of true with at most k
it's also true for infinity well
countably infinite graphs but
let's say finite graphs it's it's just
simpler to see here and the reason the
algorithm is very simple
you say that well you want to know if
nso sentence is true in some graph of
two with
k then in fact you can pull back the
sentence so that it
it's it instead of working on the graph
it works on the 3d composition
uh i don't want to go into the details
i discussed this in my slides my bigger
set of slides
but this um
the result is that i get a new formula
which is equally satisfiable so
equivalently satisfiable but it works
now on trees which are these
uh msod 3d compositions and then
you convert that into a tree automaton
and then you check the automaton for
empty so this is
it's conceptually super simple but what
is
uh beautiful is that this is the only
thing you can do
so there's this deep grid crm of
robertson and seymour which has
which says that if a graph has large
truth
then it contains a large grid as a grid
as a minor
i don't want to go into details what a
minor means but it's a
it's like a little bit similar to a
subgraph but
a little bit more complicated but
but it's similar to a subgraph and then
uh
the definition of truth is such that it
can be understood by msl
so uh the mso can isolate a minor from a
graph
and then use that minor to describe a
computation of a turing machine
and it follows that for unbounded trioit
you're going to be undecidable
so if you have a class of graphs which
has unbounded trees
then uh satisfied which is undecidable
so we now understand exactly
what makes mso's this satisfiability
decidable
it is trivial bounded through it good
unbounded truth bad
uh and uh so that's i think
pretty remarkable uh uh
there are there are variants of this
result for uh
as i i mean maybe i should come back
here i mentioned here that there's this
alternative choice where you have uh
there's the vertices only and an edge
relation and then
there's a similar story but which is
connected to a measure of graph
complexity called quit
and but you have a very similar story
on the other hand to be honest i'm not
sure how this works out i don't think
there's a good uh
theory like this for first order logic
which would say exactly what is it that
makes uh
first order satisfiability as a
structural graph property decide
okay so that's uh concludes the second
part of my uh
lecture nikolai maybe it will be a good
time to take a five minute break
this is that's what i was yeah great two
hours just a very long
stretch people can stretch their legs
run to the bathroom so can you
one week one we get back in about
five minutes from now
um
french yeah
so
so
so
um if you have already taken your break
do you mind if i ask a question
forbid no i want to sit here not moving
go ahead please so um
if i if i if i were more interested on
the
on the automotive side and basically
what are the classes of graphs
that are regular in that sense
would the trivia kind of help
describe such things as well through the
link to mso
yes thank you that sounds like a planted
question because it's my favorite
research topic
okay great
i like it because of several reasons one
of them is because it's a
mono it's wind with automata on this
topic
because there is not really a good
notion of automata for graphs
there's it's a little bit ad hoc
but there is a notion of a monoid for
graphs or a semi group for graph so it
works well
but it works especially where for graphs
of banded truth
and it turns out that so there's a
notion of regular
language of graphs defined in terms of
some kind of
monoids and
so for unbounded trees they don't behave
well
so they're undecidable and there's other
pathologies
but for bounded tree with they it
corresponds exactly to
mso logic and this is a
non-trivial result for unexpected
reasons
because uh the the what used to be the
hard part so
from logic to automata so in this case
logic to
semi groups is easy
but the hard part is from is
well semi groups to logic
and but this is true so this is a
relatively new result from like uh four
years ago
would you mind afterwards sharing the
the reference
for this on the one of the discord
channels sure sure
thanks that's really
i mean i can tell you what is the the
reason why it's difficult is that
uh if you have a a tree
uh then there's a one way to parse it
bottom up say
if you have a graph it's not clear
but it turns out that there is an mso
definable way of
parsing a graph but that's uh that's
that requires uh
some some extra results
so if i magic i i had a set of graphs
that somehow have a distinguished
note like a roots of a tree then would
it make it easier or no
would not make a difference it wouldn't
make it easier
because you want to do recursion
so i mean the root find but then what is
the the next node
uh and you want to like run a program on
it which
recursively decomposes so it starts like
maybe root of the 3d composition and
then it branches out to the two children
of that truth and then
that's not clear how to uh run such an
uh how to describe such a recursive
algorithm
using uh monadic secondary logic
but it turns out that it is possible
that that's uh
so in fact there are many nice examples
of
that actually the
usual easy direction so from
say let's automata or semi groups to
logic is is
is is is is the heart direction in many
cases
yes yes anger so i just have a follow-up
question so if you have a
way to pass the graph wouldn't this
offer the possibility to have an
automaton
you once you have a parsed graph you get
an automaton
but the way to obtain the parsing is
it's not all clear how to write it
doesn't matter
so uh you would need to have a rather
uh yeah non-catholic way of
understanding
i don't know what kind of automaton
the usual ideas of automata would not
work to part the tree
to obtain or at least for a surplus of
graphs that you get
some kind of automaton from this person
maybe that but maybe that could be done
but i'm not uh this is a
so the only thing that that i can say
with any confidence is that
well if you uh what is an automaton
yeah well one way of saying an automaton
this is a
in the spirit of bihi which is that an
automaton is an mso formula
of special shape
and if you use that notion of automaton
then i think you can prove that
on graphs of bounded sphere mso
collapses to
something like two quantifier
something like that two or three
but it's not one i think
okay thanks welcome
so what's the the special form of
of the mso4 formula for words what
well if you if you formalize the if you
write if you take and start with an
arbitrary mso sentence on words
you convert it to an automaton and you
convert it back again to mso
you get a formula which says something
like this there exists
a labeling of the words position with
state of the automaton
such that for every two consecutive
positions blah blah blah
okay so this is a formula of the shape
you have existential
set quantifiers and inside you have a
very simple formula
first order logic which in fact uses i
think two variables
okay thank you
i guess i'll wait for we can wait for
motion to
hello
i think i think we can restart nikolai
okay thanks
uh and i'd really uh as
i'd like to encourage you to interrupt
me also uh yeah
all the time so the last part which will
be a little bit more modern
is going to be about the model checking
problem
uh so uh the idea is this
i have a fixer formula and then my input
is say a finite graph
and i wonder what can i say about the
complexity of this decision problem
so it is useful because many classical
problems that you have in algorithms can
be described using
a first-order logic so if we start with
let's say this one i contain a click of
size k so this is a formula which
depends on the k
so for every k there's a different
formula but that's kind of okay
you just write out that there's a click
of size k
another one you can say vertex cover now
i'm i hope i didn't make i
will always when i write a formula
there's a mistake in this i hope
uh i wrote it correctly there exist k
vertices
uh such that every vertex that's not
among the
every edge has one end point in this
covering set
and uh so consider this hypothetical
question
maybe for every first order sentence
there is a linear time algorithm
uh it's it's the the the constant in the
linear time
depends uh on phi but it recognizes
uh graphs where phi is true this is not
unlikely to be true or i think it's just
not true
uh but uh uh
if that would be the case uh just
just i'd like to point out that the
naive algorithm is polynomial but the
degree of the polynomial depends on phi
yes you could just write an algorithm
which replaces every uh
quantifier by a by a by a for loop it's
it's it's it's
the number of nested loops is the number
of continuous quantifiers so that's uh
it's a polynomial for every fixed
formula but well it's not linear yes
so sometimes it can be done in linear
time so for example vertex cover of size
k you can do it in linear time
so there is a an algorithm uh which
checks if there's a a vertex cover of
size k
in the following time so it is a linear
in the graph size and then there is a
coefficient which is exponential
in in the size of the vertex cover so
for every fixed k is linear time
so that's consistent with the hypothesis
but
here's this click of size k is
inconsistent with the hypothesis because
there's a conjecture in a field called
parameterized complexity which says that
you cannot
do a click the click problem with an
algorithm
which is not even linear but even you
allow it to be polynomial
uh uh but with a fixed a polynomial so
that the degree of the polynomial is
supposed to be fixed
uh even if you allow yourself to be uh
exponential or whatever in k so you
cannot do it in quadratic time you
cannot do it in cubic time
the the degree of the polynomial needs
to to to depend on k
so that's uh that's the the usefulness
of
of uh well that that's uh okay well let
me
maybe continue those were things that
you could formalize in first order logic
in one adding second order logic of
course you can formulize formalize much
more
so say np complete problems such as
three colorability just say there exists
three sets of vertices
well you just write out the definition
of free colorability at the existence of
a hamiltonian cycle just write it out
it's useful here if you get to quantify
over sets of edges and in fact it cannot
be done
if you if you can only quantify with
sets of vertices
uh so there's you know many algorithmic
problems can be formalized just by
writing out their definition in logic
such as first order logic and mso
and therefore if you have a generic
algorithm which works for every
formula of say first order or mso
then that is that is going to be a
useful generic algorithm because it will
work for any algorithmic problem that
can be formalized in these
logics so here's two generic algorithms
i i begin with a very simple one uh
which is uh by cesa which says that
for bounded degrees and so here we fix
the formula
but it's not going to work for all
graphs it's going to work for graphs of
bounded degree
so more precisely if you fix a sentence
of first order logic and you fix the
degree
then you can solve in linear time uh
the question if if a graph satisfies phi
monster you look uh suspicious no no i'm
okay
so i'll give you a rough sketch of a
proof it's not so hard for this this
theorem
and it follows that any for any problem
that you can formalize in first order
logic
such as vertex cover or click of size k
or whatever
that problem is going to be a linear
time
on graphs of uh of of degree d
a fixed degree uh so uh the
the it's linear time but the the
coefficient of the algorithm will depend
on
on d and and and k
another example is for mso
and it is a famous corsairs theorem
which says that you can do a similar
thing for
mso and bounded treat so it says that
uh for every fixed sentence of mso and
every fixed bound on the tree width
you can evaluate in linear time uh
sentences of mso
on the trees of of of that tree
so a corollary of this theorem is that
any problem you can formalize in mso
such as free colorability or vertex
cover
or stuff like that you're going to be
able to do it in linear time on
graphs of bounded treat so for example
uh
you can check hamiltonian path uh on
graphs of of of bounded trees in in
linear time
in terms of the input graph as long as
the the the tree
is bound so let me begin maybe with a
brief overview of how
what how you deal with kusal's theorem
and then i will move to the first order
logic part
and such as theorems are called
algorithmic metatheorems and they're
meta in the sense that they solve not
just
one graph property such as a click
k click or vertex cover or three
colorability
but they immediately give you an
algorithm for any kind of graph property
that you could state in in the
accompanying logic so for bounded degree
it's going to be
first order logic and for a boundary
tree it is going to be not just first
order logic but
even bounded treatment so let's have a
look at the
corsair's theorem i won't say too much
about it but it follows the lines that
you would expect
so there's two ingredients one of these
which is is
of a non-logical character and it is a
godlander's
algorithm for computing 3d compositions
so it says that for every a fixed
tree width bound k you can compute
the 3d composition in linear time
uh the coefficients are exponential in k
and it says i think it's uh
so uh this is a it's a rather hard
algorithm
there is a much simpler algorithm which
is uh in robertson and seymour's
original uh
papers it's which is i think cubic and
it doesn't give you an
optimal weight for 3d composition but
but it would be good enough to get
kristal's theorem with a
cubic instead of linear but you can do
it in linear time as
shown by bot lander so it's a it's a
rather complicated construction
and then the second lemma says that once
you do so you first compute the 3d
composition in linear time
the coefficient is called is exponential
and k but that's fine because the
k is fixed and then the second uh lemma
says that
once you're given uh the three
decomposition of the sentence you can
evaluate it in your time
and the reason is because you compile
the uh sent mso sentence into an
automaton and run it on the 3d
composition
that's
consistent with what i described before
for the satisfiability problem
and then there are similar results uh
for
if you replace tree with by a different
graph measure called
clique with and rank with but i don't
want to go into those
okay so this is a this is the automata
method
uh so the automata method says that if
your graphs look like trees then you can
run three automata on them and then
that's that's what it says but what i'd
like to finish my uh
tutorial with today is that discussion
which goes in a different
direction which is not related to
abdomen and which is the story about
a theorems such as cesar's theorem and
similar ones for first order
uh so this is a this is what i wanted to
uh finish with
uh today uh a few words about that
and uh when i was using
mso the main ingredient was the automata
method
which says that you can compile mso
formulas into
automata or if you uh think of it more
like a logician it's it's something
called compositionality of mso
so compositionality of mso says that if
you
have a graph and it's it's decomposed
into two parts a left part and a right
part and then they
overlap in a very small way then in
order to evaluate mso on the entire
graph all you need to know is
what happens on the left part and what
happens on the right part independently
and then maybe some information about
how they overlap that is something
called
compositionality of mso it can be
phrased in terms of a suitable game or
or
it's well it's just a dilemma about mso
which is
what makes all of the automata methods
work
when we're dealing with a first order
logic and theorem such as the cesar
theorem
it is a different aspect of logic that
we care about for first order logic it
is something called locality
and in the theorem that i recite it is a
geifman's locality
which is the following result which
it says that every sentence of first
order logic on graphs
is equivalent to a boolean combination
of very special sentences
which look like this are called the
basic local sentences and they say
that uh there exist k vertices
such that where they're far away from
each other
so well there's some parameter k which
is how many vertices and there's some
parameter r which says how
far away they're supposed to be from
each other
and then in each one of them you
evaluate a formula which is local
and local here means that it's not a
random formula of first order logic this
phi
but it is a formula which has the
semantic but this can also be described
syntactically
property that it only depends on a
bounded degree radius around x so a
local formula is one that depends only
on the vertices which are close to x
so that's why it's called locality so
the formulas phi of x which are used
here
that they don't look far away into the
graph they look only in a close
neighborhood of x
and geifman's theorem says that this is
the only thing you can do in first order
logic
so should it be here like five excited
or
something like that or correct yes it
should be five of x i think
that's uh yeah
i i hope that fixes it
uh yeah thanks thanks for printing that
uh so there's also you can discuss the
complexity of
it and there there's work on that that
it's well not so good with complexity
as always when translating formulas of
logic into a normal form
it's it's it's really bad you do get
lots of nested exponentials
but if you think that the formula is
fixed it's fine
so necessary once again there's the same
formula for each
x i or is different it's the same
formula for each xi
uh so let's use this locality theorem
uh to prove cesa's theorem i'm going to
give you a proof sketch in my slides
i'll give you a more
fuller proof so uh what
how do you do it so suppose i i want to
evaluate
i give you i want to give you a linear
time algorithm for evaluating first
order formulas
and uh how do i evaluate a basic local
sentence
okay well
my degree is fixed the sentence is fixed
and i want to
evaluate it in linear time so for a
bounded degree graphs it's it's it's
kind of easy
because to evaluate local sentences you
don't need to look very far away because
the
the the our neighborhood around the
vertex has constant size
so you can just evaluate phi in a
in constant time by just brute force
okay that does that explains the main
idea that doesn't explain the entire
algorithm
because now you want to say if there
exists like these vertices which are far
away from each other
which have this property that you can
evaluate in constant time but this you
can work out uh
it's not entirely trivial but it's it's
it's a
slightly smart variant on a greedy
algorithm you have to be
a little bit clever there and i'll try
to explain it in my slides
okay so for bounded degree graphs you
can evaluate using locality because well
the localities are constant size you can
evaluate
uh every first order sentence in
in linear time and then it turns out
that there are far-reaching
generalizations
of of this result and i'd like to survey
two such
uh generalizations which are
relatively recent results so one is
about nowhere dense classes of graphs
and the other one is about the notion of
graph complexity which is called
twin width which is like a kind of kind
of fresh feels like
last year or the year before that so let
me begin with nowhere dense
so nowhere density is not a property of
a graph it is a property of a class of
graphs
so here are an example of classes of
graphs which will have this property of
being nowhere dense
graphs of degree at most five or seven
and
any bounded degree uh graph class will
be nowhere dense
graphs of uh three widths at most five
or or seven this is also going to be
nowhere then so for every fixed
if you bound the through it then you're
going to be nowhere dense
another example is planar graphs these
are also going to be nowhere dense
the class of all planar graphs graphs
that avoid the five clique as a minor
and in fact any excluded minor class
which covers a a
well the bounded tree with planar graphs
examples this is going to be nowhere
dense
and then so so there's a notion of
nowhere dense classes which i will
describe to you in a moment because i'll
just give you the definition nothing
more
and then there uh the theorem
is going to be that
you can do it you can do a first order
evaluation
in linear time for every uh nowhere
dense graph
graph class so not only for graphs of
bounded degree as in
says this theorem not only for graphs of
three width at most five but for planar
graphs and so on
uh and there is a and this you can you
will be able to do it uh for every class
of graphs which is nowhere dense
so all i what i'm going to do is i'm
just going to give you the definition
so when is a class of graphs nowhere
that's as i say it's a property of a
class of graphs not of a single graph
so it's defined using minors and now i
would define this a little bit more
precisely
so suppose you have a fixed radius and
you have two graphs
and you what i'm going to say is what
does it mean for
h to be the red graph to be a minor of
the black graph
but uh with this
bound on the radius r so i say that h is
an
r minor of g uh if you can
well sort of embed h into g in the minor
way except that
you need to use short paths so what does
that mean that you can
associate to every vertex of the red
graph
a set of vertices in the black graph
this is as usual as you usually do in
minors
okay and then you have the following
properties first of all
this is the r that intervenes these
parts the red blobs in the graph g
which are supposed to simulate vertices
of the graph h
they have to be connected but not just
connected but they need to have smaller
radius so there has to be in each one
you can find a vertex such that all
others are reachable
at most are edges okay so
if you talk about the usual graph minor
you don't have no limits on the radius
here
you have these blobs have to be small i
mean
small in terms of radius if the graph
has high degree then they will be large
in terms of numbers of vertices
and then the second property well is
this is what you expect is
that you can recover all of the edges in
the graph h
so if two vertices are connected in h by
an edge then the corresponding blobs in
the graph
g will have be connected by an edge so
there will be an edge from one block to
the other
so if you lift the restriction on r so
let's say you say r is equal to infinity
then you get the usual graph minor
relation
but now we care about a more
fine-grained approach to it where we we
do bound uh
this arc so we want this minor to be
witnessed in a small
local way and local it's no coincidence
because it's going to be
useful for a locality and
then the definition now is is is this
a class of graphs is nowhere dense if
uh for every radius r
you look at all of the r minors of the
class
and you're not supposed to get all
graphs
r minus of c means r minus of some graph
in c
correct okay so maybe just i think it's
a good thing to just spend some time
with this
so maybe the contrapositive uh the the
con
no the the negation i think what does it
mean to be
not nowhere dense it means
that there is some radius such that
within that radius you will find all
graphs
okay so you have all graphs as minors
but not just as minors but as miners
with
with the vertices being small blobs
bounded by bounded radius blobs okay
so this is a definition but what is
wonderful about this notion is that
there's like
eight other definitions which are
equivalent to it
so it seems to be a super robust notion
of
of of graph classes okay so maybe let's
have some examples
so the class of bounded degree graphs
then this is nowhere dense because if
you fix the radius of your blobs
then they will have constant out degree
because it's a bounded degree graph so
you cannot
go too far away so you will also for
every fixed radius r
you will get also a bounded degree uh
graph as an r minor well with that with
the the bound on the degree being
exponential but still
still being uh a constant so you uh
when you fix the radius r and you look
at the r minors of that kind
you will also have a class of graphs of
bounded degree so you will not get all
graphs
so every class of graphs which has
bounded degree
is nowhere dense example two
uh if you have bounded three with
uh then you are also nowhere dense and
this is because even if you take r
equals infinity you're not going to get
all graphs as minors
uh because it's an excluded minor
graph class uh because uh well for truth
for example you cannot find the
k plus one click as an r minor for any r
this is a it's it's a you you can show
so here it's even a stronger property
which shows that
every excluded minor class is nowhere
dense but but
for example a bounded degree is not an
excluded minor class
okay so this is a notion of density of a
class of graphs
and now the theorem says that for such
graph classes
first order model checking well it's not
really linear but it's almost linear
so it's it's a theorem of growing
creature and zebras which says
that for every nowhere dense graph class
there is an almost linear well you can
find an algorithm which is well not
linear but one
n to the power of 1.1 and to the power
of 1.001
you can evaluate first order formulas on
that graph class
in n to the power and the power can be
arbitrarily close to one as you wish
so it's it's almost linear model
checking for every uh
nowhere dense graph graphql so this
generalizes cesar's theorem
it generalizes the variant of kursal's
theorem for first order logic
and it generalizes a lot of other
theorems and in fact it generalizes all
theorems
in the following sense but if you care
about
well if about classes that are close on
their subgraphs so
your property of graphs is closed under
eliminating vertices and eliminating
edges
which is the case for all of the
examples that i gave
then nowhere dense is the exact
border between when you can do a first
order model checking when cannot
in terms of say fixed parameter
retractability
so if you take a class which is not
nowhere dense
and it is closed undertaking sub graphs
then model checking on this class is as
hard as model checking on on on general
graphs
so uh you inherit all of the all of the
trouble
from that and this is rather i mean it's
just an unfolding of the definition
because if you are not nowhere dense
that means there's some number r
say r equals 12. such a that you can get
every possible graph as a 12 minor
and then by closure under uh
subgraphs it means that you get well
roughly speaking all graphs with
with edges simulated by paths of length
uh 24 i think
and there are some small technical
issues but it's it's it's it's rather
straightforward to see so
here there's again this nice dichotomy
so we know exactly what it
what what it takes for a class of graphs
to have
a linear well fixed parameter tractable
in this case almost ah
linear model checking so if it is almost
uh
if it is nowhere tense then it is uh
close to linear
and if it is not nowhere dense then it's
it's it cannot be done in quadratic time
it cannot come in cubic time and so
okay sub subject to to some conjectures
about
fixed parameter tractability so that is
one line of work
and i'd like to finish my talk with a a
final
rather recent development which is
something called twin width
so what is it well here are some other
examples of
graph classes where first order model
checking is in linear time
so you take instead of planar graphs you
take complements of planar graphs
it's a very stupid trick yeah so instead
of saying ed you say non-edge
and the opposite so of course it's the
same problem as evaluating first or the
logic on planar
graphs but it is not a nowhere dense
class of graphs
you can well you can so
because well it has lots of edges okay
that's
that's one of the characterizations of
nowhere density
is that you do not have a quadratic
number of edges
so okay that's it's a stupid trick but
it's already a class that's not nowhere
dense and it's
it's easy or you know a complement of
any other nowhere dense class that's
also going to be easy because
well complement the first order logic
can deal with complement
another example which doesn't fall into
the stupid complement category but
almost does is graphs of clique with at
most five
so clique with a notion of graph
complexity similar to trioit but
but different it's meant to cover
cliques and graphs similar to those
i will not go into the details but this
is you can also do first order in fact
mso model checking
i think in linear time definitely in in
quadratic time or something
fixed parameter uh so these are classes
which are not nowhere dense and
they're importantly they're not close
under subgraphs so they're not covered
by the dihotomy theorem that i mentioned
before
so it would be nice to have something
which covers
these dense classes dense meaning lots
of edges
in this case and well this is not the
theory that i will mention now it
doesn't cover all tense classes or
classify them in some full way
but it's it's i think it's an exciting
development which which
generalizes many results about dense
classes which is a notion of a graph
complexity called twin width
so what all that i'm going to do is i'm
going to define twin width
and this will be roughly the end of my
talk today
so what is this twin width so
imagine you have a graph and you
partition the vertices into
some groups in this case there's three
groups abc okay
so uh i say that two blocks so
groups in the partition are consistent
if they're connected in the same way
so blocks a and b are consistent because
for every vertex no matter which vertex
i choose an a and no matter which vertex
i choose in b there's always an edge
so i don't care what happens inside
block a i don't care what happens
inside block b i care about between a
and b okay so they're consistent in a
yes way
and blocks b and c are consistent in no
way in the sense that for every two
vertices there is a non-edge
okay and blocks a anc are not consistent
because uh
sometimes there is an edge and sometimes
there's not an edge okay
is this clear so now uh using this idea
i'm going to define
a twin width and this is something
thomas and i don't know what region
that i don't know from from last year so
it's it's it's pretty recent and it's
the following definition it says that a
graph has twin width k
if you can obtain it as follows so uh
you can have a sequence of partitions
with the following properties you begin
with the trivial partition where every
block has one vertex
and you finish with the partition which
is trivial in the other way
okay so you uh like you merge you're
going to merge partitions
then when you go to the next partition
you just merge two blocks of the
preceding
partition okay so at each step you're
going to merge two blocks
okay and then uh
well the last of course
the place where the entire definition is
is item c
which says that at every step
of this process and you look at one
block
in the partition pi then it is
consistent with almost all of the blocks
so
with at most k exceptions it's
consistent with every other block
in other words if you think like in the
i step you think about the graph
where the vertices are the blocks and
there's an edge
for an inconsistency then this
inconsistency graph has a degree
out degree or in degree with degree at
most k
okay it's clear
so uh that's the definition let's see
some very simple examples
let's say clique well click for the
moment
uh uh a click it has twin with zero
because you can decompose it without any
inconsistencies
whatsoever so you uh uh
i should have uh yeah i should have
started out with my singleton blocks so
i don't draw them okay so initially
everybody is in the wrong block okay
and then i merge the first two blocks
okay so what are my inconsistencies
there's no inconsistencies because uh
well uh there's an edge everywhere
and then i merge the first three where i
add the
third vertex to this block and then i
keep on merging and at every moment i
will have zero inconsistencies so it has
a twin with zero
okay uh another observation is that this
is
uh not it doesn't care about edges it
doesn't make a difference between
edges and no matters so
if you complement it uh the same
decomposition works because it's uh
instead of being a yes consistent it
becomes no consistent but it's still
consistent
okay so this is a measure of complexity
which it doesn't uh it's like uh it's
it's not positive in the sense that
fewer edges is better it it doesn't care
about complementing glass
and in fact you can show that a bounded
uh
tree width implies a bounded quick width
implies bounded equipment so these are
measures of complexity the middle one i
didn't mention it but uh
i i mentioned by explain it but the
bounded twin with
generalizes these so uh every class of
uh
bounded every class of graph which has
bounded through it
will also have bounded liquids but you
can convert a clique with decomposition
into a twin with decomposition i don't
know i don't remember
maybe k grows exponentially or something
or maybe it doesn't i
i don't remember but it's a definitely
bounded implies boundary
so any algorithm that will work for
bounded twin width is going to be
stronger than an algorithm which works
for bounded frequent
and uh in fact there is an algorithm but
for first of the logic
so uh in the original paper in the paper
that defined twin with the show
that for every if you fix their twin
width
and you take a fixed first order formula
then you can evaluate it in linear time
on graphs of
twin width at most k there is a cadet
here
so there is no botlander algorithm
so uh the algorithm
it requires not only the graph on input
but it requires this twin width
decomposition
and then you can evaluate first order
formulas in
in the near time and so far well it's a
new thing but i i believe there are no
uh
i i don't think there are fixed per and
there's no linear or cubic or whatever
algorithm for computing a twin
decomposition
for every fixed game and uh so that's i
think
a a a nice new development and there's
some some theory being built
up about it so if you want to look at it
i encourage you
to have a look at it and i think that's
all i wanted to say
in my talk so uh there's this uh
beautiful story which is rather recent
about understanding uh
for which graph classes first order
logic can be effective it can be
evaluated efficiently like in linear
time and then
there are the strong results which say
in these cases you can evaluate it super
efficiently in linear time
and in the remaining cases it's
impossible not
linear not quadratic not anything so
these are and there's
quite a lot of deep theory involved
there
and then there's also the classical
story of well
relative classical of mso and kusar's
theorem
and uh there's but there's also some
some some some developments
in that and i think that would be the
end of my tutorial so uh thank you for
bearing with me for all of this time and
if you want to have a look then you can
on my website and i think on on simon's
website you can find links to
extended versions of these slides and
thank you
thank you mikolai
so i i have one question
so in some sense i would say the most i
don't know
famous or in practice uh kind of a
tractability result for this kind of
question of course are the two results
in in temporal logic right the ctl model
checking
and and ltl model checking are both
linear in the size of the structure
to the follow from anything that we we
have seen here does this follow from
anything we've seen here because this is
true for arbitrary
arbitrary graphs right
[Music]
no but i think there is an automaton
perspective on it no
of course there is a dominant
perspective there's a
there's a there's one that maybe
[Music]
it might not be your perspective okay is
there another one okay tell us
no i don't know i mean uh i'm just
trying to be controversial here
no no i mean the the key thing is that
the quantifier in something the
quantifiers here
it's a second that you can think of them
of over arbitrary structures
this is boss ltl because i'm we're
asking is there
we're asking what question about the
graph they are it's a monadic
logic here in some sense but the set
quantifiers are special
and they are about paths they're not
about sets
they're about path i think that might
might be special
here which means there is a maybe maybe
the the key thing is to look at yet
another logic which is in between first
order and monadic and full monadic
and i think there is i think maybe
wolfgang thomas have looked at it called
past logic or the quantifier
are overpass
yes so this is uh uh
so i tell you what is my perspective on
it which is
that these are and it is well it's not
these are one way to look at uh temporal
logics
is that you have a multi-step process
where you label your structures by the
true
values of more and more complicated
formulas of node formulas
this doesn't really work for ltl or
well for a ctl star but it does work for
ltl and
on strings and it does work for a ctl
on graphs
and i think this perspective of adding
more and more labels
is is connected to a very classical
topic
in automata theory in algebra which is
chronos decompositions
so i think this would be for for me uh
the the perspective that is useful here
and this is a a line of work
that you concentrate on note formulas
which have just one free variable x and
then you keep on
adding labels to your structure which
say more and more about it
this is something that was developed by
i think it's a very beautiful
a very simple idea by by look secretfun
which is these unary negation fragments
for example so you are
so this is a another perspective
on on such temporal logics uh which is
connected with these crown rod
decompositions which i think are a
beautiful
topic and a bit under utilized in in the
literature in my opinion
any other questions from the audience
again remember there is a
more extensive set of slides and
recording available should be i think to
the institute website
well if there are no other questions and
let's say thank nicola again for a
wonderful
tutorial and
people from the west coast can start the
day and people from the from europe can
finish the day and we'll see you all
tomorrow here continuing
take care bye-bye
thank you nicolai thank you
actually may i ask a quick follow-up
question here you go ahead
uh so this um the
the parts in your definition of twin
width which was uh related to having a
sequence of partitions
is that sort of related to the same
being able to parse the graph that you
mentioned
as in if i have if i have partition
partitionings at every level
that satisfy your condition but they're
not connected through these moves
together
then it doesn't it would be strictly
weaker than the definition that you gave
right
can you repeat the alternative so you
you
you kind of start from this singleton
partitions and the step by step go to
this everything in one partition so
imagine
the alternative in which i have these
partitionings at every
level if we think about the the this
kind of partitioning lattice think about
it
right but but your definition requires
me to be able to connect the dots right
i can
all of these have to be related by these
moves merge moves together
is this extra condition as opposed to
just the existence of a partition at
every level
such that such that it satisfies your
condition is it related to the same
parsing of a graph as in i have a
strategy
well of course it is it is i mean
[Music]
if you think about this this lattice of
partitions
uh then it is what you want to have is a
path through this as
you said yourself a path through this
lattice which
says that it's it's uh the consistencies
are
yeah you want to have that and and
finding this path well it's it's nobody
knows how to do it i think
no i'm more so my first question is the
existence
on the exist on the existence of the
past so imagine a slightly weaker
definition
at every level as in at every
level of this lattice you do have a
partition that satisfies the consistency
at most k inconsistencies but the ones
from each level are not connected
together by measurements
i i mean i'm not an expert in twin but
my intuition would be that this
is very different that
you can have complicated graphs such
that on every level you can find a
simple partition
but you cannot connect them by a path
somehow that would be my uh
my impression about it so you can the
fact that you have to do it in a
well consistent way i think it should be
different
right i think my question was general to
kind of try to get an intuition why
they have to be connected what is what
purpose does does that serve
exactly but i know the purpose
is that imagine that what you're going
to have is a first order evaluation
algorithm
which uh computes some information about
the if partition
and then where since the i plus first
partition is very similar
it doesn't need to do too much more work
it's like incrementally going to change
it so that's the idea
that that's what you came from okay that
that makes sense
and and one other quick question is uh
the the
government theorem the fee uh is that
computer though
uh yes well yes so
okay sounds suspicious because first
order is undecidable on
uh on graphs
but the the guy from ethereum says that
you can compute some fee but
well probably the optimal ones are
uncomputable
but some non-optimal ones are computable
yes so the theorem says that it
exists or it says that it can be
computed
okay okay yes so it's like
many things about what most things about
first
were semantic properties of first order
logic are undecidable on graphs
but this is more like a syntactic
translation somehow
it's well a bit more it's more
complicated but in the spirit of
converting a formula into
a pre-next normal form so this is
there's an algorithm which does this i
mean
probably computing the shortest possible
prenux norm well not
probably but probably computing the
shortest possible prenux normal form is
an undecidable problem but
a a uh sum is it is the same but
computing the fees
is a simpler question than the actual
model checking question or no it's
equally hard
well computing this well it
i think it's this well it's it's the
algorithm is non-element the out the
size of the output formula is
non-elementary
so it's worse than the tower of
exponentials it's a it is a tower of
exponentials
or something it's worth or worse i don't
remember
that in terms of the size of the formula
so in that sense it's it's
very bad but since you think of the
formulas being fixed
then i i think they're incomparable
these results because one is
non-elementary
in the sense of a tower of exponential
or worse
but on the other hand since our
perspective is that the formula is fixed
we don't care about that
thank you very much for the excellent
talk thank you okay
and i'll i'll send you the the the the
the link to the paper yes that would be
yes thank you very much